NARRATOR: Maria has spotted
the fresh tracks of a snake
in the sand, and
it could still be
hiding somewhere in the tomb.
John joins them to
lend some support.
Good luck.
OK, if you're still in
here, I come in peace.
Tapping a bit.
Maria, don't tap
it, just lift it.
Yank it.
I don't want it to end
up falling on our mummy.
JOHN: Just be safe.
NARRATOR: Many of the
snakes in Egypt are deadly.
JOHN: You OK?
Yeah, there's tracks.
Lift the stone.
You want to keep back
from the door, please.
I got it.
Well.
JOHN: Nothing?
I tell you what.
I'm going to carry
on with my work
and leave you with your snake.
NARRATOR: Maria and
Tricia can't be completely
sure the snake is gone.
I removed a hole
where it ended.
OK.
You scared him off
anyway, I think.
NARRATOR: But with
the clock ticking,
they decide they must press on.
We have to be careful to
distinguish what is mummy
and what is dirt here.
Yes.
This stone can go.
NARRATOR: By excavating
the body from the mud,
they hope to discover more
about the role of this person
in Gebel El Silsileh community,
but the state of the mummy
makes their task tougher.
More pieces.
Little piece of skull.
Yeah, I got more here.
Burnt.
They burn to such heat that
the white bones turn blue.
NARRATOR: Ancient looters
would often burn the mummies
they found inside a tomb.
They're after gold and
by burning the mummies,
it's easier for them
to open them up.
Very sad.
NARRATOR: The ancient
Egyptians would have dreaded
this kind of mutilation.
They went to huge lengths
to mummify and protect
their dead believing that
to succeed in the afterlife,
key elements of the body and
soul must be preserved intact.
The first was the Ren,
your identity and name.
It lived for as long as
your name was spoken.
Ib was the heart, the
seat of your soul,
the good force in your life.
Sheut was the shadow,
an image of yourself that was
reborn every day at sunrise.
Ba was the unique personality.
It left the body in the form of
a bird at night and at death.
The Ka was the vital
essence, the force
that animated the individual.
And the Khat was the physical
form of the body, which must
be preserved or mummified
for the dead to be granted
eternal life.
I feel like I personally
get attached when I'm working
on a mummy, and you feel like
you're getting to know them,
and you feel like a caretaker.